hey guys i'm off the grid for august and
here's something that happened on the
former news network cnn
do you want to see president biden the
senator run for a second term
well what i want to see right now
is that the congress of the united
states working with president biden next
year
develop an agenda that says to working
families and the elderly and the kids we
understand your pain and that we have
the guts
to take on the big money and trust at a
time when we have more income and wealth
inequality than any other major country
on earth you know wolf you've heard me
say this again and i think recent events
point this out this country is moving
toward an oligarchic form of society
where you got three people on top who
own more wealth than the bottom half of
american society you got three wall
street firms
that have asked control assets of over
20 trillion dollars that's the gdp of
the united states unbelievable wealth
and power at the top while the middle
class is in decline and lower income
people are really suffering we need to
work right now next year with president
biden on an address on an issue on an
agenda that addresses those issues well
let me rephrase the question do you want
to see him run for reelection
look right now my concern is
electing more democrats in this midterm
election so we can finally address the
needs of working families that's where
my mind is right now